he's at my height but he's so wham i
remember he used to come to
school in a string vest in the summer no
uniform
string vest school trousers and
wallabies and a do rag
they couldn't stop him he did what he
wanted in school
he turned up when he went he left when
he wanted
okay party people what's good
sun is shining nowadays gyms are open
your boys have been back
in there working bro my breast is
sore bro titties are sore titties are
bouncing and sore
you men are ready give me a healthy
breath all that healthy when you walk
a gloop and it goes
yeah boy your boys are back in it so
it's long for you lot
it's actually long for you if you want
to jump on jump on
uh because this summer when we drop our
summer merch
you might need to be physically prepared
that's it's on you now
you know it's on you we've told you
you've given you a pre-warning
it's may now in it so you got to what
july july
couple months to get your act together
get bro you got a solid eight to ten
weeks get your [ __ ] together cause the
summer launch
the summer launch is gonna be flossy
you're gonna need skin out
you're gonna need skin up so make sure
your [ __ ] is tight
all right um moving from there guys you
know the drill by now
today's episode is brought to you by the
one the only
manscaped so manscape they've brought to
us their patented lawnmower 3.0
which comes inside their perfect package
3.0 bro we both got one of these each
each bro
it's the thing it comes with everything
you need
to keep trimmed and cut free and
smelling nice brother when i say
smelling nice
they've got the crop preserver which is
an anti-chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer bro
you've never heard of such bro
never hurt you deodorize and moisturize
your balls
you slip on their anti-chafing boxes
good to go
you're sliding firm i feel like a figure
skater
you're gliding a figure skater
yeah bro it's different i feel like i'm
at the um it's different you know when
you're the roller disco
are you doing that back backwards you're
just looking back just damn things
that's how i feel get out my way because
i'm coming
bro i'm sliding through it i'm awake
because i'm coming so yeah bro oh my
days get 20
yeah get 20 off as well guys and free
shipping using code
s n g at manscape.com
that's 20 off free shipping manscape.com
don't forget to use the code
sng unlock your confidence and always
use the right tools for the job with
manscaped
and without further ado get into the
episode let's do it man
so today's fun fact do you know
okay i know we've spoken about animals
before but i've spoken about octopuses
before but i've got another octopus fact
as well octopus fact gang here we go
so if a female octopus is hungry and
doesn't want to mate she will entice a
male
and lead him to and mislead him into
thinking they're about to mate
then she will strangle him to death and
feast on his corpse in her den
for a few days so she just freezes she
just arches
she freezes up freezes up the pump frees
up the body frees up the titty them
so when man says he's like come come
come come come
he wraps her legs around his neck and
chokes him out takes him to the dunya
takes him back to the yard
wraps the tentacles around the neck
man's thinking i'm about to eat some
octostrange
you know strangles man to death nah
strangles man to death and yams him
yams him bro these men have all the
power
i've said it before i'm tired of it they
use and abuse us as and when
as and when they please bro the power of
the p
man it's crazy that how men are fickle
in all parts of life bro
all parts of life any
any animal any environment you want to
do it you holler the man he'll do
whatever it takes for the puss
he'll do whatever it takes for the puss
it's so
embarrassing it actually is humiliating
when you watch it and you're like bro i
would have done the same
ten times out of ten i'm flopping that
bro she's freeing up the nana she's just
come through
and she's banging as well i'm going i'm
going next thing i'm just there
death just dying well she's yamming me
ass first nah nah
we're fake human beings we are we're
perfect men are so fickle
as a gender we're just pathetic we think
we run [ __ ] but
we don't when it when oh when the the
naan is free
nah we don't know what day it is just
smell it in the air
you don't know what day it is did you
ever used to watch buffy the vampires
there
back a day back a day yeah yeah yeah so
there was an episode
yeah i think what was her boy bridging
called zanda i think his name was zonda
i don't know barbara so let's call it
zanda
zanda there was an episode where there
was this woman
who could transform into a praying
mantis
and she was feeling your boy xander but
apparently they've just been teenage man
that's gone missing i think she might
have been a supply teacher or something
okay
she was feeling your boys and up yeah
yeah and there's a couple man that i've
just been missing
yeah so people i started looking into it
and they realized this [ __ ] is a
praying mantis yeah she transforms into
a praying mantis and praying mantis eat
their
partners in it so they let them knot and
as soon as they're not
they eat them and i think they lay their
eggs in like the corpse or whatever
i don't know praying mantis i know the
women are just much bigger than the men
yeah and they eat the men
after they not and that terrified me and
i remember when i was watching buffy
vampire said i was a kid
so i didn't understand the power of the
people power of the peace i didn't
understand the power of the p
yeah and um i i remember watching it
thinking nah
nah like why is he falling for this
he didn't care fam the way these men
were trying to warn him
like bro she's not about it she just
wants to let you nut so she can eat you
all my man heard was nah nah yeah all my
man was hearing was not because he said
not again
gang all right cool bro yeah like i
don't understand why you're fighting me
on this
i'm trying to not i'm trying to i'm
thinking xander why are you fake like
that brother
i don't know bb yeah why are you dumb
bro yeah she's gonna yam you yeah
and now i i can imagine myself being he
was a in high school
yeah 18 17 18 a teacher banging
wants to know no way you're there in a
heartbeat
all my all my bridges can tell me she's
going to eat me alive i don't care
anymore
it's folklore no one's eating me alive
bro shut up she's not going i'm a
grown-ass man i can defend myself come
on
she wants to defend myself oh she wants
the tool just leave her just let it be
don't be jealous don't be a hater
why are you hating you're a hater that's
all literally why are you hating shut up
bro the teacher wants your boy to sharp
firm the l and let me do my thing
yeah boy i know he's pain now it's
actually crazy actually i understand his
pain
but uh yeah the male species need to we
need to get
something together yeah yeah we need to
organize we need to
have a sit down have a meeting and try
and
overpower all this situation because the
way our mind works when
we're in that zone of p we just don't
think we have no mind
that's it we have no mind they take
control of it
we have no mind it's right we fall for
all the tricks
all the tricks and you can fall for it
time and time and time again
and just fall for it again he's like oh
not again
ah not again it was so fickle
go through it oh man octopuses go
through it
bro jesus the animals the animal kingdom
is a different kind of terrain and i'm
not involved
i'm not if we wouldn't survive we
wouldn't survive a day in there bro
speaking of the power of the p actually
yeah this is actually this goes through
when you hit a certain age
it's p or d it doesn't matter okay so
you get old in your body
it's taking p or d in your body i um
i've always wanted to watch 90 day
fiance in it
okay but i don't have sky anymore okay
um i just have like the streaming
services yeah yeah
so i don't have tlc i don't have
discovery plus i don't have all these
channels
on i've always wanted to watch it any
little advert i've ever seen of it i
think oh that looks juicy
but i also can't be bothered to search
online to find it
i don't want to watch it that badly yeah
yeah if it's on you'd want yeah yeah
yeah i want to get confident just
watching it of course
so but i was on tick tock today and
there was a tick tock page dedicated to
nine day fiance eclipse that was my
entire morning
this morning that was my entire morning
yeah yeah i went through
it bro and you know the donnie was like
the no neck and stuff like that
my mum was on their eyes peak ah speak
but there was one
don um this lady she's like in her 50s
so grim she's sat into a donny from
nigeria in it
obviously obviously his name is usman
bear man in nigeria called usman
this man is uh it's an islamic name is
it yeah yeah it's not
a nigerian name it's an islamic name and
there's a lot of islamic people in
nigeria
yeah because my man's called usman
obviously camaro usman
is the fighter and he's this guy
um who smiled his best friend who lives
in his yard is also called usman i was
thinking oh it is a matter of smiling
i know like 10 nigerians and three of
these ones
but anyway so usman is like a music guy
okay and check this he goes by the alias
soulja boy
like soulja boy like soulja boy but s o
j j a
sojo boy okay okay oh my god and he's
chatting to this yeah
in america who's like in their 50s yeah
and he calls her baby love her baby love
baby love
and um she's gassed off him yeah yeah
yeah
gassed off are they seeing each other
like just your face time and ting yeah
yeah
yeah
and um she's telling allah begins and
then like
he's like 30 but she gets jealous
jealous fab man wants this green card
sorry but he's been chatting to her for
two
years multiple times a day for two years
danny loves her he wrote a song about
her
the song was [ __ ] terrible obviously
[ __ ] terrible
she said as soon as she heard it she
died um
and she gasped on my man she wants to
bang him through that she wants to
bang it she wants to bang him bro and um
she said she said she chatted to her
bedroom and she was like all right big
mounting
he's like a select celebrity over there
yeah he had like twenty thousand
insta she fought that was basically 10
million yeah yeah
she thought he was gone clear bro yeah
she fought he don't need me
yeah she used to screenshot like any
comment that he got from a girl on his
like
insta post she was a screenshot of
cinematic who the [ __ ] is that
it was long bro big woman in her 50s
right anyway
so um she's like i'm gonna go to nigeria
and meet my man and her friends stop
stop stop this is getting stupid now
and then she said their friend said like
how do you know like he's gonna stay
faithful to you and all this stuff and
she's like ah that's the trick
he's told me because of obviously the
prevalence in aids and all this stuff
over there
that he's never ever had sex without a
condom never in his life
um and he's a muslim as well and this
helps or whatever
he's never had sex so without a condom
never so as soon as i get there
raw she said raw no condoms raw and he's
gonna he's gonna buckle that he's gonna
love it
and i was literally thinking like she's
older
but yeah she's so busted by the same
time i was thinking
that's right as soon as you because
obviously i don't know what she looks
you know what she looks like so you've
got a context of how ugly this is yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah as soon as you hold raw [ __ ] she
was banging to you in it
that's the mind of a man yeah yeah yeah
yeah you said raw priest was like
bro she said it's raw no condoms bruh oh
that's sexy when she was trying to leave
her bedroom gave her a condom and said
you don't know if he's clean or whatever
she said big man i know he's clean she's
dashed the congress she's they're not
having that
[ __ ] these condoms bro she said [ __ ]
these condoms damn
banging him but then as soon as he
picked her up from the airport he met i
said oh baby love people laugh
and then they interviewed him afterwards
isn't it no what do you think of her
name's lisa and he was like um
obviously i've only seen her from like
here up from like face time
she's like the tummy hard african accent
tommy like to tommy like i didn't know
she had that he said but she still got
like a nice personality in there
and his boys came to pick her up so it
was like his two
housemates came to pick them to work for
an airport and then um
they were like putting the [ __ ] in the
in the boot and they were like he was
like oh what do you think of lisa kind
of thing
and then brethren was like tommy in it
tell me you got tummy brush
i was thinking right these men are
superficial fam
superficial brush all of them were like
tummy in it tummy
geez it was dread and then he was at a
work like a work team with some
producers on that and he was like oh my
baby love lisa's coming all this stuff
chatting up for the camera fam one of
the guy was not playing along
he knew he was on camera he wasn't
playing he was like let me see this lisa
let me see
she's from america he's like oh they've
got women in america he's like yeah is
that run me to sick
man took the phone looked her
kissed his teeth and stared at him like
this this is him so say you're usman
yeah it's a baby love and i was like oh
sorry yeah yeah they've got women in
america i must say that
like why even doing this
said is this a joke is this a joke
no is this a joke what are you doing how
old is she
he said this doesn't matter man said i
need to know
it was [ __ ] hilarious bro he wants
the green and he play
he just wants the green card because
like he'll talk about lisa lisa lisa
aspirations in life and stuff like that
and he's like ah i can't wait to get to
america brother
when i get to america they go i'm gonna
get straight into music like
i know i have the talent to be the most
popular musician
in the world if i can just get to
america he loses it when they gas him
about his music
he forgets what he's doing he forgets
that he's trying to finesse lisa
and all he talks about is getting to
america it's the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ]
oh it's so funny that's so peak but
you're so funny bro it's peak and
there's one
uh moroccan don who's doing a ting with
some
fat white thing fat
and she wants to be effects she's
hugging him up lifting him up she was
like i love you and he's like yeah i
love you too
and then she'll be like look at me look
at me i love you and he's like
i love you fam when they got
uh they asked about like oh how's
everything going she goes off to marcus
stay with me for a bit
and they're like how's everything going
and then
she's like oh last night was amazing we
got so intimate every night and he's
like yeah it was cool
and then uh she's like we had sex his
face was just like
are they next to each other they're
sitting next to each other holding hands
and she's like we had sex and then the
guy's just like oh
don't remind me he you could tell he
wants to be like why are you telling
these man that we had sex for brother
no we didn't are you airing out the
thing you're baiting out the whole thing
just get my [ __ ] visa broth
just get it just get i want to come to
america i'm tired of this let's just get
married already
and then he made up this elaborate thing
like obviously being a muslim country
and stuff like that he's like right
there's a muslim country
like the landlord has been called by the
police they know we're staying in the
same room
we're gonna have to get a new uh like
hotel with separate rooms
and she's like oh what swear down and
he's like yeah yeah it's just dread
so they got a new hotel separate room so
she's like i'll just sneak in my room
and they don't know
no no i'm not doing that and on road she
tried to hug him he's like
stop don't touch me on road like you're
not allowed and he
you can tell when he gets wound up he
forgets himself yeah yeah he's like
shut up brother stop like you're so
angry he hates her
he [ __ ] hates her he just wants a
card anymore he just wants a card
and divorcer and dip that's all he wants
but it's like
obviously with these kind of shows it's
clear that that's his
intention that's his motive how are they
running these shows how are they letting
men ruin people's lives like this you
know bro i don't know
these men will do anything for
entertainment how are they
but how are these women these producers
don't care how have these women
also not seen the previous season
i don't know i actually don't know
that's what's crazy to me i don't know
how they just are so naive that they
actually believe like nice calm
sexually i'm going to change him like he
like he loves me fam you man don't get
it
like you're putting me on this 90 day
fiance thing because you think he's
having a pop
he loves me you're a big man he hates
your guts
and he's actually willing to [ __ ] you to
get what he wants that's
that's a different level of desperation
oh 100
would you rather okay would you rather
do that
like if let's say you were in one of us
men's like ultimate situation you're in
nigeria for example
um and you're trying to patent a thing
to either england or america and you
need you need to get out of where you
need to get your situation yeah yeah and
it's the fattest
ugliest whatever woman you've ever seen
and like
okay i have to do this or would you
rather
going back to um that mma fire would you
rather hold on to that um truck for 24
24 hours in the desert one go through
the whole thing go through the
whole his whole journey would you rather
do his whole journey
you don't know whether you're going to
fail as a good seed or
do a 90-day fiance team with the most
ugly track and
big man i'm going to watch this show
where everyone's going to watch it
it's on it's on tlc's on everything
you've got billboards and all sorts
you're back-to-back
like this oh this thing now back-to-back
together at last
nah what would you do where are they now
um so either france is in ghana
14 months yes treacherous journey
to europe to europe yeah or do two years
us mounting with facting lisa yeah
because they're both as strenuous
they're actually both as bad as each
other yeah
yeah francis gets all the credit usman
gets no credit whatsoever
he's going through it went through it
first did you put yourself through that
that's why i'm not putting myself
through that thing is i'm not built like
man man i like to think i've got
i'm strong mentally nah i'm soft fab
let me take fat thing lisa let me take
that
i'm not going through what you went
through i feel like i'm strong mentally
i felt that because
i think every guy feels that every guy
feels like they're stronger than they
are they'll think they're in france
which comes to shove i can do anything
in this world like if i have to do it
i'm going to do it not until like you're
two hours like oh my god this is
fam this is as soon as i get that first
hand cramp on the dusty road
i'll i'll tell the director to cut
send me back send me back to now jerry
let me do this lisa thing because this
is stressing me out this is stressing
i've got 14 months of this no no no no
no
i'll [ __ ] a fat girl as many times as i
have to
you would ever get up you'd pop pills oh
he's been popping viagra he
must have must have been but you never
know on that first one
when she said hit it raw he might have
been like
i'm willing to take the hit for this she
said hit
it raw first raw thing is that though
yeah it's not what you want is it it's
not what you want as your first warting
skin on skin and she will swallow you
whole
she will gobble you up she'll probably
give you dirt though
she'll probably give you dirt you're
definitely banging her i can only tell
i can always tell in that situation i'm
doing the i'm doing the whatever her
name is i'm doing any fighting in that
situation
i'm not holding on to the thing for 24
hours i promise you that
because i would i know i would die with
this lisa thing
there's no real danger oh
there's humiliation but there's no
danger question then okay
here's a question okay okay okay okay
okay okay
here's a question yeah yeah would you do
it so say
you know you went back to nigeria and
you ate yes
say if your parents [ __ ] left you
there
left you there yeah never kid locked you
off yeah they just hated you yeah locks
you off yeah
left you there you graduated school
you've got no money nothing you have to
take jobs as like a
flipping pot washer yeah like you've got
nothing
in nigeria there's no way you can come
back
so you lived here until you were what
yeah it goes like 12 13. i think so yeah
i think about 13. yeah so you lived in
england pristine england until you were
13
your dad dropped you off in nigeria and
you've been there ever since
you're 30 now you've been pot washing
it's dusty you live with like six other
breads yeah
it stinks yeah obviously it stinks
and you're not even in lagos you're in
back end you're in
backhands you're livid fast it
[ __ ] stinks yeah if a thing
if a facting lisa pops up in your friend
request on instagram yeah
would you do what he's done to get back
um i think yes because
probably the reason why i say yes
because yeah
you said i've been in nigeria since i
was 13 and i'm i've graduated and i'm
still pot washing fam
17 years i've not achieved anything in
life
oh yeah not anything not at all bro so
me [ __ ]
anything is better than doing what i'm
doing right now you know yeah
so i would 100 percent [ __ ] this lisa
chick just to try and get
a visa or whatever to come back today oh
okay england 100
100 i knew i wouldn't even tell my
roommates goodbye i packed my [ __ ] in
dip
i don't even tell them i'm going i'll
dip 100
100 i'd have to you would i'd ha i've
got no choice in that matter
i've got no choice in them i'd have to
but that's a that's a funny
that that um what's the night day fiona
thing because i've seen the guy who
known that guy and i've seen another one
there's another nigerian guy that's got
like a one all over and he's with a big
ting i don't know
their names but his faces are vividly in
my head
because you said that um lisa went to
nigeria this other chick went tonight
drew as well yeah
again i don't know if that's if she's
the one but it is funny these songs will
get
do anything to get anything yeah yeah i
know i know it's long
but i would i'd have to i'd have to
james
i might say i've been port watching for
17 years i'd have to oh i have to bro
the thing is i'd come back probably
invite find a way to make some pee
i'd find my parents and i'd [ __ ] bang
my dad in this drawer
i'd have to man i fear how the [ __ ] did
you get it
what did you get as soon as he opens it
because he's gonna know it's me and
he'll gasp
and try and shut it he's showing your
foot in the tin
scraps straight
i say i want to
[Music]
then you just fit your foot in the
little gap and you just pry
it open oh nah
that's the funniest thing i'd be so
angry oh
you could never bump into me in central
man
in manchester and just for us to become
boys and tell me that's how you got here
yeah
i'd be on the floor
i'll be such a whirlwind of emotions
yeah yeah yeah yeah i
genuinely wouldn't know what to do or
something make you think
because when it reminded me of when you
told me the francis story
it just makes you think about people
live
completely different lives bro
obviously you're only entitled to live
the life you have
and you can only see the stuff you've
experienced then blah blah blah yeah
yeah like i feel like everyone has been
through hardship in their life
but he is on a different level oh
i don't think anything different not
many people are capable of surviving
what he did
no you know not at all like that's
that's mentally
exhausting physically exhausted like nah
hardship is different man
i couldn't do it that's why i said i
could never do that i'd go at least i
have to
i couldn't hold on to that thing james i
couldn't hold on to that thing
you said in that story that i'm a woman
with a child she's ready to dash her
baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah as soon as you said
that that's that's when i knew the road
was rough
oh bro it was a real bumpy road to throw
two punch you know he went through that
just a box man nah he's a champion
though he is
he deserves it bro i'm not doing that
what a story i promise you're not doing
that i know what i know
seven hours in i'll take a deep breath
and i will let go
i'll just let the wind take me take me
the dust will cover me in seconds
instantly people look back and be like
did you just see that
[Laughter]
because you'd be so weak you'd have no
energy
no food nothing let go they won't even
hear you
fam they wouldn't even i'll just spin
off into the wind
snap my neck and just be done with the
whole affair be
done with it bro because they must have
done that countless times there are
people that would have died
on that transit nah bro that's different
levels of hardship
bro speaking of hardship you never mind
them that are just
rolled yes just yes yes yes yes yes
born lived and died for road yeah
has there ever been a time in your life
where you just like like i said i like
to think i'm built different
but when push comes to shove i'm just
soft fat yeah i'm
too domesticated i know you're
domesticated has ever been a time where
you thought like
i could pat on road if need be but then
realize like i
i physically couldn't um
i feel like because of who i've
surrounded myself with like when i was
growing up and stuff i like the culture
and the music i listened to i always
thought i could pat in this road life
yeah yeah yeah because when you're
for example when you're when you finish
school and you're all in your collective
groups and stuff
and you bump into another school that
are probably waiting for the same bus
to go home or whatever yeah yeah it's
kind of like a rivalry yeah you always
think um
when you were your boys bro i will temp
anyone
all these man you know and it's like
if it was like a one-on-one thing or if
it was like a big guy versus me i'd been
that age i'm like because it's not gonna
pattern
it's just not gonna pattern so i don't
think i've
ever wanted to be in that realm of
roadside
but there was a phase or there was
obviously a time where i thought it was
it was the thing to be yeah you know
because that's all
not necessarily all that was all i was
associated with but it just seemed
cool bro doesn't it just it just and
these men have got
cars at like 18 and they're driving a
car car
just seem cool like a car car car and
there's always a
painting in the front always and you're
just like
this is that's the life couple pills i
can shot a couple of pills and this is
what this is what i'll be living that's
the life they're living that's that's
it laying in every morning it's the life
bro there's i've got a story time there
was one day when i knew it was
not for me hit me hit me hit me was not
for
me hit me so all right let me set it up
so i'm about 16 yeah maybe 17. i want to
say 16. i wasn't driving yet so
definitely like 16.
um and there was a time me and my boys
were just out and about as late it's
probably like one in the morning
and we're ready to call it at night 16 1
a.m my parents wouldn't have it
really my parents wouldn't have that 1
a.m 16 maybe 17 then i don't parents i
tell you
now my parents wouldn't have that
but continue your story every lucky
child
my parents wouldn't oh my dad i think to
be fair
i think my mum was strict not strict on
timers but i was always one of the first
guys to have to
i always had the earliest curfew you
told me you told me with that party
story
yeah until i was about 16 17. and then
it just
do what you want yeah yeah okay um so it
was cool like that
but i must have been about 16 maybe 17
but i definitely wasn't driving yet
because i remember had my bike
we were at my friend's house um just for
a few drinks or whatever
well just for a chill i can't really
remember and yeah we left about 1am i'm
ready to call it at night
as we're leaving two my boys go this way
and it was me and two of my other boys
going this way
so we're walking up walking up and
there's one dom from my area i won't say
his name or anything like that
my man was the most rodeos of roadies
roadies
i think everyone had that growing up
yeah yeah in their different criminal
of course one criminal of course he
wasn't mentally stable fam
so my mom also got drunk and got in a
disagreement with his brethren
okay and man got me
and so me and two of my other boys and
he said to us you men are rolling with
me tonight
luckily for one of my boys his house was
here we were literally just walking past
his doorstep and i said
i can't and literally just went straight
and i was like [ __ ] i would have got him
with him bro
and he said i was like oh i need to go
before i even finish my sentence i said
i need to and he said
i'm telling you now if you man trying to
run away i'm gonna [ __ ] knock you out
and i was like cool he's like you man
rolling with me tonight
i was thinking it's one am fam the
night's done
i don't know what you want from us so me
and my boy look at each other like
the last is the last one i don't know
what he's got in store for us
but i don't know what he's got in store
for us my heart would have left my
channel so it's me my boy
we're stuck with him now until he lets
us go
so we're rolling around he's out i've
got a couple jobs to do
i was like i mean what does that mean
it's 1am
it's like a thursday it wasn't even oh
so i've got a couple of jobs but i've
got a couple jobs to do you manage
with me tonight [ __ ] now so
we um we're hanging around with him
and he's like cool there's a couple man
i owe me some money
i need to pick something up and my girls
just [ __ ] off to her cousin's house
because she found out i was [ __ ] her
cousin
so she's locked herself and now i'm
going to get her back you man are wrong
with me
and if i see any of my boys tonight it's
beef
and i was like he lives in a different
realm
what does this mean this is a weak night
for him
so as we're walking walking walking bro
he was when i say he was wham
he was strong street strong yeah
that's a different bro i had my bike
yeah and i'm peddling he's like yo give
me a baki
i was thinking bro you weigh so much
yeah yeah i can't
he he weighs like debo weight and he's
trying to get my back pegs fam and i'm
struggling and he's a [ __ ] sake buff
get on the front and he told my boy to
get on the back he's like leave your
bike there you might wrong with me
you go james you get in the front get on
the back and i was like he can't push us
fam from a push not even from a kickoff
he sat the bike up and just pedalled you
could hear the chain
straining and his quarters went baba i
was like
debo i'm not playing right at me sitting
[ __ ] like this on the handle bus
thing shaking from and i said stay the
[ __ ] still
and the thing was lean he said stay the
[ __ ] still fam
i was there because you can't see him as
well he's back here
you can feel his breath on your neck bro
he powered through it
ah as we're riding down the street quiet
street fam
one crackhead starts walking up the road
he was like gang
this [ __ ] owes me money bro he said
get off got off the bike
he dashed my bike in the bush i was
thinking peek you know
he launched it i was thinking wow that's
broken
and he rolls up to my man yeah bro
he rolls up to my man he's like oh let's
call the the crackhead steve is that
steve
steve and then the guy said oh yeah yeah
yeah he's like yo yo yo
um he pulls out a spliff you say you got
a liar and steve's like yeah i like
runs man the lighter let me light the
spliff
looks like steve and he's like oh have
you got that um i think it's like 50
degrees you got that 50 quid
it's like oh no no i got it and got it
i'll swear yeah you ain't got it
and he was like yeah you know it's very
you know i'll get it i'll get it but
like i haven't got it on you tonight
like i'm literally just
coming from a mrs i was going my house i
haven't got it on me i've got nothing
he's like
yeah yeah and he's like yeah sorry man
i'll give it to you tomorrow it's like
yes tomorrow that's fine it's like
and he's like yeah yeah cool thumb he
grips the lighter
and bang man in the head with it with
the metal bit and when i say he
proceeded
to bludgeon this guy to the floor with
solely the lighter
his knuckle did not touch this guy's
face he beat the living [ __ ] out of this
crackhead
with the tip of his lighter fu had
just bang bang where's my [ __ ] money
bang bang go get it bang the guys on the
floor
crying grown man crying tears fam
i have never stood so still in my life i
bet
i was dead jaw's swinging look to my boy
my boy looked at me
i wanted to run i bet he would have
caught you no he'll caught me fat i'm
[ __ ]
he lives on ends he's going to see me
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day
if i run now i'm not allowed to leave my
house ever again yeah yeah yeah
bro he finished the guy off and left him
there bleeding on the floor and i said
let's go
and i was like oh my god and this is
this was meat one that's the first stage
one oh my god did he get the bag
yeah we got i got back on the bike he
was like get your bike i got back on the
bike and just like
pushed it and you can hear that
the mechanisms [ __ ] it up
um and then um so the next thing is
alright i'll go pick something up so he
rode to his house and he had like a bush
in his front garden
man's like james that get under there
there's a plastic bag i need you to get
in the bush
the bush is fat i said i need to get in
the bush there's a plastic bag on there
i need to give me the plastic bag
and i was like [ __ ] and my boy was like
bro
do not get the man all right under his
rear fight do not go in the mic
he said if you see it just say it's not
there was that gang thumb went under
there
and i expected the size of this bush i
expected there to be
bare debris bare litter everything nope
cleanest bush i've ever seen and a fresh
white bag
folded in there fam and i was like
yo i can't see you know and i was like
it's in there just keep looking and i
was like
staring at a family i was like big man
i'm telling you it's probably not here
yeah he said broth
if you don't get that [ __ ] bag i
don't know how much will i get back in
the background
just get it just get it
if you don't get that [ __ ] bag
the fear that would have ran through my
bones james
bro i was like all right man there i can
see it
grips the bag it was a gun obviously
felt the cold hard metal of the gun
never felt anything like it bro i didn't
think it would feel like that yeah
i thought it would get good to me do you
know what i mean like you know when you
feel it anyway
this was right the balance the weight in
it just feels perfect
film i picked up on my hand with like
that
my wrist collapsed when i picked up the
ting was heavy
heavy and i was like gang grips the
thing out
and i was like sick in my head
he's drunk fam man put the thing on my
head and i was like you've told me i've
told you this
taught me that bit before you've never
told me this whole story bro but the
thing in my head
i was like stop big man i'm not even
playing anymore
and in my head i'm thinking he's
he's so cold he would probably just
dumping me off
he's been to penn every six months since
i can remember
like this is mine into my man for some
reason i was not even scared fam i was
like big man
don't like in my head i was thinking
best case scenario i pissed him off
so much that he drops the gun and just
beats me up
do you know what i mean i'll piss him
off so much that he'll just drop the
thing and just
punch me up and then it's a wrap fam i
was beefing my man about this thing he
said he's not even looking shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't give a [ __ ] like drop move the
thing from my face now i'm not even
playing
like i'm not even joking i'm sorry what
are you gonna do i will slap it and then
i'm gonna slap you
like i'm not even joking i move the
thing and luckily he knows he's
so much bigger than me that he's just
found that funny yeah
he's like two years older than me and
like yeah twice my size so the fact of
me saying i'll slap the gun and slap you
he fought
all right cool cool like you got some
balls yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know i picked the right guy yeah yeah
and then so he allowed the ting
and then he was like oh it's not even
loaded and then like click the ting and
it actually wasn't i was thinking i know
this is gonna go off
as soon as he kicked out so you get
imagine it went off
oh you have no idea how fast i'd run as
soon as you bet back i would dip
dip but anyway so that was that he
grabbed the thing
typical cliche back at the belt and was
like let's go
[ __ ] what's next so then he was like now
i need to get my girl
she said i [ __ ] my girl's cousin she
found out so her now and the cousin both
hate me
so i'm gonna go get the cousin so he's
the cousin was in my class
bearing in mind not even my class she
was in one of my english classes
um and obviously we went to school
together and stuff i've never spoken to
this girl in my life
bro you just know of her i know of her
he's like
james on the door i'm not no and i tried
to reason with him as a big man
it's two o'clock in the morning now if i
knock on her door
she's gonna be thinking what the flying
[ __ ] is my man doing here
like why is he how does he even know
where i live he's like shut the [ __ ] up
another door my man hid behind the door
here
he said shut the [ __ ] up another door
right i knocked the door i see a look
through the window
and i'm like and i i heard i'm thinking
here we go
i had a like oh it was just james and i
was like this [ __ ] is crazy
what did you mean she just changed why
are you here if you knocked on my door
and i looked
i would shut the thing and i'll run
upstairs and i'll look down like
that to see who else you're with yeah
yeah yeah
you know kevin asks like get caught gets
caught wankered and he's like who you
got would you if somebody watching
that would be me i would sprint upstairs
and look out the legend
who you would you is somebody with you
i'll be thinking what the
[ __ ] yeah like the incredible hulk might
as well knock on my door yeah like i
would be so perplexed
she's like i was just james i was
thinking she must be high as a kite
or something she's not thinking straight
fam she opened the door
my man bust through the door like ah
they sprinted for a moment sprinting up
the stairs
door's swinging i heard the mum in there
just like what's going on
both of them spinning up there there's
laughing screaming crying all sorts fam
me and my boy got our bikes and we
spotted oh i'm not spun off
i skidded around the corner i went one
for skidding from my skidded
and bombed it all the way home i've
never looked over my shoulder so much in
my life
well i was terrified bro terrified worst
night in my life
even when i got home i knew my man
didn't know where i lived but i was just
there
peeking for hours thinking oh he's going
to suss me
you wouldn't have slept a wink oh bro i
didn't sleep the whole night
the next time i saw him he was he is
like he never knew even happened
it was wild fam wild
that's scary that was it i knew i wasn't
built for road
i knew i was i just thought no is this
what it takes to get the bmw
and the bad [ __ ] no yes
it's not worth it cuz man rocked a
crackhead with a lighter
bro oh i can remember it like it was
yesterday it dropped him
he was left feeble and shaking oh
[ __ ] man i was like wow
this is really the street this is really
real
this is what road looks like it reminds
me of um i watched a
sh documentary on a documentary show on
bbc iplayer
it was like organized crime sometimes
economically it's called organized crime
colon
science it's based in money so yeah
based on shooting
one of my friends one of my colleagues
at work told me about it and he was
saying how
one of the characters one of the
characters one of the guys is
the stature of he's like your boxer
stature
he's got the broadest shoulders and the
smallest v
but he's like six four six five he's
been in and out of pen and he's been
doing like dodgy [ __ ] he kidnapped to
break bangs up a breath of all sorts
and they should obviously there are
cameras in every everything everywhere
so they're showing a time where they
were trying to process him in pen
in like the reception area of the of the
of the jail
and he was like nah i [ __ ] it i'm not
going into the cell what are you making
me go into the cell
one of you [ __ ] make me go into the
cell he backs off you stop i say
one of you make me go into the [ __ ]
cell i see if one of you steps closer to
me
i'm gonna knock you the [ __ ] out before
i get in there because i'm going to jail
now so i'm taking one of your
[ __ ] with me
fam there's about seven of them there's
him i'm watching it through the screen
i'm thinking oh my god he's gonna go and
take it
oh my god who's gonna make him go do you
know what i mean yes i know what you
mean
built for that i'm not going in there
i'm not i'm not handcuffed i'm not and
the woman that arrested him was
the woman the person i arrested him was
a woman oh yeah and it's one of those
power plays where she's like
she knows for a fact that she he could
kill her in a heartbeat you know um
and it's she said something along the
lines of
when i think when when they went to get
him at the yard before they took him to
jail
there was about seven eight nine ten
cops they told him to [ __ ] come down
and say if i'm
if you see the amount of red dots that
were on man's stomach when he was coming
down the stairs
nah he's a jailbird he's a lethal weapon
oh he's
he's well he's a big guy man he's a big
and the thing is he's not even
he's one of those guys that look like
the kind of
guys that will always get banging girls
always get banging girls
yeah it's one of them i know you mean he
was
broad broad it made
no sense he would have knocked everyone
out but yeah it reminded me of that it's
a good jesus
good show to watch my man the man i was
discussing he's like that
he's like that he's not tall he's at my
height but he's so wham
i remember he used to come to school in
a string vest
in the summer no uniform string vest
school trousers and wallabies
string vest and a do-rag and
in like year 10 his chest was
wham wham how are they letting my
comfortability
they couldn't stop him he did what he
wanted in school
he turned up when he went he left when
he wanted he did what he wantedfu had
they couldn't even stop him from coming
in if he didn't if he wanted to come in
he could be expelled if he's coming in
he's coming in and it's just not worth
the drama yeah just let him do what he
wants
because he'll burn everything just let
him do what he just doesn't care
bro certain man that just born different
he was one from like 14 bro
i remember looking and thinking jesus
christ bro you look like a grown ass
man and a jacked one at that oh it makes
no sense the chest is bursting through
here
what's going on says string investor to
do right string
bright green bright green string vest
and a do-rag
nipple just ah is it jamaican yeah
nipples just out he didn't give a [ __ ]
on purpose and i was thinking why put on
the school trousers under school shoes
if you're gonna rock up like this you
might have made it a muffy day bro
yeah but i think he did it as a bigger
[ __ ] you yeah
just i do what i want one and but yeah
bro
he was bill bill
he will rock man out like my boy he was
there that night said he saw him on the
night out
dropping man one time like multiple men
like on a night out it was him bare
drunk white guys
and my boy said he was just there
knuckles in and just hooking and it took
one hook each he was dropping man like
dominos
nah bro drop it by like dominoes you can
see it now just
bang bang just back just drop in him and
he'll take one bang here and just
whack his next level bro
i don't know if he's alive or not to
this day i don't know if he's even alive
he was a next level guy the thing about
things like that it makes me wonder how
do they even get to that stage
you know because obviously it reminds me
of um no it doesn't it doesn't remind me
but it
my brain went to um the night stalker
and obviously was saying how in like
episode three they showed his backstory
and that how his dad tied him up to a
[ __ ] cross in a cemetery yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i'm thinking how does one get to that
kind of mental state or that kind of
stage where all he knows is this and
there's no right or wrong
it's just what he sees this is his path
in life bro you know
and there's nothing that can change his
mind he's set in stone
man said if you don't get that [ __ ]
bag from the
bush i said i can't see it if you don't
grab that [ __ ] bag
bro you just knew when he was serious as
soon as he said yeah
i just knew he was serious i just had to
grips it the man said
i grips it my hand buckled
and i was like i'm not made for this my
joints
aren't made to hold this kind of
weaponry jesus
man yeah i knew road was not for me fam
it wasn't for me [ __ ]
anyway let's do one's gotta go bro yeah
let's that was a that was a good story
because you've told me about the gunting
in the head before but you've never told
me the full thing
yeah bro it was a long night oh i can
imagine
anyway guys as you know one's got to go
um this
edition again is about people all right
people
and like actors and [ __ ] yeah
so yeah um
so first line this is in terms of like
ignore the movies they're right they are
in
in this one but more of
the best you've seen them in a movie
does that make sense
so ignore the actual movie itself
okay so ignore like the acting but i'm
just saying thinking i'm just saying to
you like
in terms of how peng they are in the
movie and or like the most pain you've
seen them in a movie
yeah so for this one margaret robbie
scarlett johansson cameron diaz
angelina jolie one's got a girl yeah
yeah
angelina jolie okay why because
i might say cameron diaz yeah but i
thought you would say
bro you know i watched the mask the
other day
do you remember the mask with jim carrey
she is
unbelievably banging in that movie she
is
disgracefully banging her sixth appeal
in that movie doesn't even make a liquor
sense yeah yeah and in um
i think there's a movie she's in with is
it justin timberlake like sex educate
something like that
oh the teacher thing bad teacher and
she's here yeah about
the one with my man from how i met your
mother the
sex tape one she made a sex the sex tape
movie
the bear from hammer your mother which
prayer
that's like the third lead marshall
marshall yeah
i think this i think the movie is called
the sex tape i think sexy people i
haven't seen that one
the sex spell is nice in that as well
yeah bro and um even um
there's something about mary she's
banging i can't remember that music
she's
banging bro she's exciting about her
now there's something about her brother
something about cameron diaz um actually
julie has never i've never had
i've never been fussed about her i've
literally never ever been fussed about
her okay
uh i know she's banging but like in
comparison to
scar scar joe i used to be obsessed with
scar joe
when i was younger i was obsessed with
scar job obsessed and then um
who was the other one again i got robbie
mutt
she's different this is daddy what does
daddy want
her standing woman bro man's dribbling
on the floor
she's so sexy man said her pawn was like
cocaine
even when he's married with kids
everything man said i just
couldn't resist the thing
oh my god i know what that's like
couldn't resist the thing that's sexy so
yeah it's um
what's the face can go angelina all
right bet
cool i think this one's better again
um this is in terms of peganus maya
drama
yeah daphne joy oh
yeah claudia san pedro oh
that's an impossible request
that's an impossible request they're all
banging in their different natures
claudius and pedro ashcash
daphne joy and oh gee oh gee maya jammer
oh maya jama she's different
um i'm gonna say
the one that has to go is
strangely enough claudia san pedro she
has to go yeah
strangely enough this is how stupid and
pathetic this
is yeah but you were the one that
introduced me to claudia san pedro
back a day years ago okay banging makes
probably
banging but
this is how pathetic this is because you
were the one that introduced me to her
and when you introduced me to her you
you that was just your
insta ting yeah yeah yeah yeah it it
made it feel like she was your girl
even though she wasn't and because she's
your girl i just can't see her like that
jeremy you're such an idiot
i get your logic and your reason but
[ __ ] me mad i hear that but it's not to
the degree of
it matters until this situation right
now yeah of course where i'm just
thinking like bro
i've had dreams about ash kash and my
jammer
dreams like actual dreams about them
like they're so banging fam
it's scary they are so yeah i'd say
i think in that one claudia and daphne
i've followed her for years yeah yeah
and you introduced me
yeah she's been banging since while now
yeah she is
banging bro she doesn't look a day older
and i think i've followed her for like
10 years
doesn't bro it's crazy really good
so yeah she's gonna have to go cool mum
all right this one is in terms of
who you [ __ ] with the most not in
terms of like sex because of the guys
uh michael scott dwight street
jim halper andy bernard oh
one's gotta go and he's going okay and
he's going those who don't know those
are characters
from the office yeah he's going bro andy
i like
i like what he brings to the show yeah
and what he does to the dynamic yeah
especially once he's manager yeah but he
just doesn't ever mesh with anyone
he's not he just doesn't fit in which is
probably perfect that they promoted into
manager
because he doesn't fit in as one as as
in that office scenario yeah yeah that
means
it just really doesn't make sense and i
like him but he just doesn't i don't
know he just doesn't
it was just cooler without him like in
the early seasons before
there the whole dynamic was spot on and
then they brought him in
and it didn't it didn't change he didn't
change much but it's just like
these angry streaks yeah and he just
like you can just tell andy's not
supposed to be here yeah and then they
make him manager and you're like that
fits better because now he's away from
like everyone else and
yeah but yeah uh everyone i love
so was it michael michael scott dwight
shoot jim harper oh yeah they're the
they're the players bro yeah the ogs
they're not going anywhere
they're not going anywhere all right
cool okay um
toby maguire andrew garfield toby
maguire
tom holland and who miles morales
miles morris we don't know who miles
morrison is actor-wise yet dude
otherwise no
but as a context as a context term
maguire
okay gone why go on why well it's
actually funny because
obviously you we grew up on tony maguire
spider-man yeah so to us he was like the
og
yeah jesus jesus sorry guys but
it i think just how easy
it was to drop him from me
as soon as andrew garfield stepped on
the scene it was like toby mcguire who
it was literally like why the [ __ ] was
he not spider-man all along and then tom
holland again
he didn't make me he didn't make me feel
that way about andrew garfield tom and
andrew garfield to me are both
great spider-man but if you go from toy
maguire to andrew garfield i'm like why
the [ __ ] was totally
ever spider-man and then if you go to
maguire tom holland
i'm like why the [ __ ] was tom mcguire
spider-man these guys are so much better
of spider-man
uh mars morales obviously we only have
like the spider-verse version which i
just i
genuinely think the into the
spider-verse is like the best spider-man
movie ever made it's it's
it's so good it's a great movie so good
so i'll keep him just for that yeah and
i'm sure when they bring him in
he's he's going to pop and the game pops
as well that he's in so
yeah toby can get scrapped cool cool
cool cool yeah yeah cool there's the
last one henry cavill
or henry cavill however yeah that's it
jason momoa
oh yeah yeah yeah dwayne the rock
johnson yeah well this is my boy crash
listen
kind of like boy crush slash like one
exactly yeah yeah so henry cavill yeah
jason moell
dwayne the rock johnson yeah and chris
hemsworth oh
i didn't know i was thinking who's he
going to pick last it was a toss between
chris hemsworth and um
who plays um captain america what's his
name what's his real name chris evans
chris evans but chris hemsworth for me
thor is so different yeah
yeah he's too big yeah
um and he has more i feel in my opinion
he has a bit more sex appeal
yeah then chris evans oh that's a tough
one man
strangely enough
i'm gonna have to dash henry cavill you
know
i'm gonna have to i don't want to but
there's a i saw a tingle i would say uh
potentially chris hemsworth
okay but there is
um a tick tock i saw the other day where
a girl's talking about like
um getting like spitting in her mouth
okay
and she's doing this this whole bit
where she's like ah she's mouthing so
she's
following the trend of someone who
invented this like
to speak the actual speech itself but
she's lip-syncing okay okay so basically
the the tick-tock is her
lip-syncing talking to her friends like
ah
what's all this like spit in my mouth
girl's always talking about spitting my
spit mouth that's [ __ ] disgusting why
why would anyone spit in your mouth and
actually say in the last little like why
would anyone spit in my
um spit in your mouth and then she says
i would never let anyone spit
in my and she gets the might and then it
turns then it's the scene
in um i want to say it might be the
scene in infinity
war where
um yeah in infinity war where he's on
the um
where thor is on the gunners of the
galaxy ship
and he's vex and he's sitting there he's
got like the hoodie on the stuff
and he's like stan he just like stands
up out of a chair and like walks towards
the front
and he's vex face and he stands in front
of i don't know who he stands in front
of
but obviously they've edited out who the
person they stand and edited her
she's edited herself in so he looks like
he's standing in front of her like
looking down at her yeah yeah and she
gulps fam and she's like okay cool i get
it
and it's fam no sauce yeah the sex
appeal from him standing there staring
yeah vex yeah and then just standing up
or walking over to her and looking down
at her
you can see what she's on about
[Applause]
her ovaries are burning from burning
and you're like dad that's a man you
know mm-hmm that's a real
man so for that henry conversely
even though in in superman when he's got
the beard
i'll never forget when them don's try to
push him and he
and they butt in the bar and you just
think
bro that's a guy i feel like in my
opinion out of these four
he was one of the first because
obviously they're all like superheroes
as well
yeah he was one of the first alpha male
superheroes i could remember yeah he was
like a proper like yeah project bro
jacked
i'm like [ __ ] you're a man jack you're a
man i'm like and i was surprised that
they've
they replaced him or they've taken him
off you know yeah
jacked bro he went on all the gear for
that right he must have
all the gear big [ __ ] the rock's
not going anywhere he's not going he's
the he's the alpha male
period he's not going anywhere he's not
going anywhere
so yeah it has to be henry on that one i
think fair enough bro um
jason mama was just a different breed
dear from breed bro bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah doesn't matter ain't
going nowhere man
he's the he's out of all of them he's
the one who knows he's the buffest
he just knows he cleans up all the [ __ ]
i've ordered them he's the only one that
i genuinely think
could steal a girl from the rock because
he's got that bad boy vibes
okay i feel yeah i get you because i
feel like
jason momoa acting as aquaman is still
the same jason mmm
as a human being as he would be just
walking chris hemsworth isn't thought
different different different henry
cavill is different
superman he's a posh boy henry cavill
royal life is a [ __ ] posh you
i know my man when he shaved his face um
when thor shaves his face and stuff like
that
and he's actually like chris hemsworth
guy but he's just not that guy yeah he's
just a wham good look he's a warm good
looking guy
the rock is just he's the [ __ ] rock
yeah swinging a whole bottle of tequila
on ro like he's nothing
um but then jason mob is just like the
coolest [ __ ] on planet earth
who wears just like doc martens and
ripped jeans and just like throws
a scraggy beige top and he's just like
what's up
he's he's a good guy he's a good guy
he's he's the guy bro he doesn't really
ain't going nowhere
fair enough mum so yeah that's that cool
gang man um all right let's do
am i the author let us know what you
guys picked at home yeah
i'm glad you guys enjoyed that one i'm
glad you enjoyed that one
i knew you i knew that daphne drove my
jammer one was sweetie
yeah bro that was a tough one
more of that to come right so this one
yeah isn't necessarily am i the [ __ ]
so this is crazy like this guy sent this
into us i think it's hypothetical so i
don't think
this one is a real life situation based
on what he's
he's messaged us since okay but
it it yeah it just um
when i read it i was like i had to tell
him bro elaborate
what are you talking about so basically
he said what's up guys i love the pod
i said i know i'm part of the problem
but don't block me please
i've got bills to pay i saw that that
popped up not too long ago yeah a couple
days ago yeah yeah i saw that pop up on
my phone so man said i wanna know though
say you had a friend when you were
younger that used to do act a little gay
or sus
for the laugh but grew up to be super
rich and famous and arrogant and an
[ __ ]
would you take him to court for his
previous transgressions against the boys
and secure your bag what the [ __ ]
bro i said i don't even know where to
start give me more details what are you
on about
so then i said okay me and my friends
were discussing it
if before money i was doing borderline
sus [ __ ] with the boys
like a little head caress or a leg
caress
strictly for the laugh and now after
money i've turned into a major [ __ ]
um like assaulting people while i'm
drunk and then bribing them to keep
their mouth shut
see he says he's hypothetical but when
he says like a certain people when
they're drunk and breathing to keep
their mouth shut i'm like that seems
very specific that's not hypothetical
yeah that seems extremely specific
is it cool for my boys to sue me now
based on the sushi i used to do so they
could get it back
i'll let you go first i know what i'm
going to say but i'll let you go first
give me that thing and say that so recap
yeah give me a recap recap
so recap is i'm a guy
and for the banter i do weird gay [ __ ]
pre-money pre-money so when we're
younger when we're teenagers oh grips
your leg
squeeze your body yeah like stroke your
face i'll just do such [ __ ]
now i'm older i've got cake
but now i've got cake i'm a prick so i
might get drunk in a bar
smack a guy up and give him some money
to shut up
and just act arrogant and do [ __ ]
[ __ ] now you don't like me anymore
because i'm acting like a prick
so you think even though i haven't done
anything to you you think
i wonder if i could take this guy to
court and sue him based on the
borderline sexual harassment [ __ ] he
used to do to me yeah yeah
um so i can get money off him so he he's
asking if he's the [ __ ] for wanting
to do this
i feel like of course in my opinion yes
he's the [ __ ] for wanting to do that
yeah without a shadow over that because
one he's not done anything to you
two yes you feel like he was doing such
[ __ ] in the past and now that because
he's got p
he feels i can get away with stuff like
i've said it before like if i if i win
the lottery i'm gonna slap someone and
shut you know
obviously i'm not gonna do that yeah but
he's clearly living out his dreams
yeah yeah um but within the same breath
i don't feel like it's
um might say i'm the guy i don't feel
like it's my place to
want to take someone or take someone to
court considering they've not done
anything to me
you know yeah he's trying to bring up
stuff that happened what 10 15 years ago
yeah like there's no what just because i
have a bag
if i wasn't the the easiest question is
if i wasn't rich
would you still would you try and sue me
yeah if i if i used to do such [ __ ]
and now i'm a prick regardless of the
money would you try and
get something from me like
i don't know like that's like what we
were saying in the patreon episode
before about like the council culture
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's like
but because i've got p now you think you
you think you're entitled to it yeah
you think you have a reason to take my
money from me because you don't like me
i hate [ __ ] like that do you think you
own something regardless i hate [ __ ]
like that yeah like you think you
deserve something
because i used to annoy you with some
[ __ ] back in the day and now you think
i'm a bad person so i deserve to lose
the money
and because he used to do such [ __ ] to
me i'm the one who deserves to get the
money
that's there's no hypotheticals about
this bro swimming people for anything is
such [ __ ]
like the idea of if you want justice for
something
accepting money from them is enough yeah
is such [ __ ]
like i think like if you're a criminal
go pen yeah
but when you want to accuse someone of
something and they're like brother you
deserve to go pen
and they're like oh he's there's a mill
he's a mill quiet and they're like oh
okay
like shut the [ __ ] up like you're a
hypocrite yeah yeah yeah you don't want
you didn't want justice
yeah yeah yeah yeah you wanted something
you didn't want justice you knew they
were rich and you knew you were going to
get something and that's why you did it
if you went to joey like okay that's
cool but i want the p it's basically
what you say
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that hold that um
he didn't specifically say am i the
[ __ ] but that's basically what he's
asking and yeah you would be the [ __ ]
if you sued him for that you would be a
serious [ __ ] because now it just
sounds like you're fishing for [ __ ]
100 oh he used to do some [ __ ] when we
were kids like let's call it sexual
harassment and get some pee
nah man this is crystalia all over again
bro isn't it happened 10 years ago like
nah man nah nah nah bro [ __ ] that's
that's [ __ ] that is [ __ ] that's
weak boy [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up that's
fuckboy [ __ ] like
shut the [ __ ] up that's actually [ __ ]
[ __ ] stuff like that would get me angry
bro
literally shut up what is it yes to be
fair
the brent the friend or the ex-friend is
an [ __ ] for doing the stuff he does
oh that yeah yeah he's not a good guy
we're not condoning that or whatever
he's
a prick for what he does but you as the
ex-friend you shouldn't even want to be
want to associate with
yourself with that yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you know what i mean it doesn't make
any sense
why you want to do that it's down bro
but yeah like
i'm done with that question that's like
yeah you are you're the [ __ ] bro
that's 100
how's that you're blocked now check it
now
look at your phone now you're blocked
now i'm playing
um i said i got bills
um but yeah yeah yeah that was that's a
crazy one yeah but
i hope it was hypothetical by the way
you made it like it was i really hope it
was
it doesn't sound hypothetical it doesn't
sound but yeah it really doesn't sound
hypothetical but um
yeah thank you very much and um yeah
guys peace
i'll catch you on the next one